Welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
Thank you for being on.
Thank you for the people who submitted questions.
Remember if you didn't get a chance to submit a question and you have one,
feel free to type it in the chat right now.
Or if you think of one during a call,
we have one, two, three, four, five, six, seven questions or something like that.
So let's get started.
Remember also to look at your
members homepage for any updates under the announcements.
Typically, we're all post any announcements.
Okay, let's get started.
First question, how long does it take to feel
if you have antibodies to brain tissue?
Okay, so there's a test done that we have done on lots of people
called the Syrex 7x array 7x.
That's a test for neuronal antibodies.
So the main neuronal components that you could develop antibodies
are tested in that array.
If you have antibodies to neuronal tissue,
it can affect more than just your brain
because you have neuronal components outside of the brain and spinal cord.
So let's say if you have antibodies to synapse in,
which is protein that is found in your brain,
in your neuronal synapses where the nerves come together,
you could say the joints of a nerve,
that's going to affect peripheral nerves as well.
But typically, we're doing that test on people
that might have upper motor neuron issues,
meaning brain type issues, inflammation,
maybe early dementia, or just forgetfulness,
or weird symptoms that could be related to pride alone,
or temporal alone interference.
So if you do, if we do run that test,
and the person does have positive antibodies,
how long does it take to heal?
Well, you're really, it's your lifetime.
So it's not a matter of magically making antibodies go away.
So typically, in the stage of with brain issues,
is that you could get inflammation in the brain,
that could be from a variety of sources,
could be from a pathogen like Lyme disease,
or strep, or something like that,
could be from trauma, from concussions,
you get a car accident, it causes, you know,
the trauma causes inflammation of the brain,
to just emotional stress, to, you know,
all sorts of different things can cause inflammation of the brain.
So everybody gets that at different times,
you get certain levels of inflammation of the brain,
and definitely with people who have a cancer diagnosis
if they're taking medications,
that is a big cause of inflammation of the brain.
That is, quote, unquote, chemo-brain.
Chemo-brain is when you're on a harsh medication,
like chemotherapy.
Those medications can cross the blood-brain barrier
and causes inflammation of the brain.
Well, prolonged inflammation of the brain activates certain type
of cell in your brain called your microglial cells,
the microglial cells are really the scavenger,
quote, unquote, macrophages of the brain.
It's part of the immune system of the brain.
It's part of the cleaning out of the brain.
They move around the brain with their little tentacles
and grab onto inflammatory cytokines,
grab onto pathogens,
and they help get things out of the brain and clean up the brain.
Well, prolonged inflammation can damage those microglial cells
so they can be damaged and stay in what's called a primed state.
So primed microglial cells are damaged microglial cells.
They don't work the same way anymore.
And they can affect all sorts of things.
So I'm explaining this because there's a progress.
First, it just doesn't get antibodies to brain tissue.
They get inflammation,
and then they get primed microglial cells,
and then they end up developing antibodies to neural tissue.
So you have to kind of walk backwards
and try to heal a person with antibodies to their own tissues.
Your decrease in inflammation, that's your biggest step,
try to heal the brain, stimulate neurogenesis,
stimulate neuroplasticity, brain exercises.
You will you ever have those antibodies to brain tissue go away, maybe.
But again, the antibodies to neural tissue are just a sign that there's damage there.
If you don't do anything,
you just let it progress.
That's when it's going to progress to MS,
or other demyelinated diseases.
It's going to progress to neuronal inflammation.
That is that is unstoppable,
and you're going to end up with Parkinson's
and full-blown Alzheimer's.
So it's not really how long is it take to heal.
It's what do you need to do to move towards healing?
Once you have that damage and you have antibodies to brain tissue,
you're just constantly working on decreasing inflammation of the brain.
It's not something to take lightly.
You have to be active and be working on decreasing inflammation of the brain,
and healing the brain.
Hope that helps.
Next question.
Why does it see more people are susceptible to issues with bedbedness all?
Well, so the issues that a person would have with any medication
have to do with their ability to detoxify said medication.
So if let's say I have a decrease ability to detoxify fedbedness all,
then fedbedness all is going to do more damage to my liver,
and that's why I would that's that made issue a person would have.
So even if fedbedness all was working to kill the cancer,
you know, you don't want to kill the patient by causing liver failure,
and then you die of liver failure, and you didn't die of cancer
when it makes no sense whatsoever.
So it's a matter of balancing between being able to tolerate fedbedness all
and how you'd measure any drugs, toleration, would be a,
do you have side effects of that medication?
Well, typically with bedbedness all, there's not side effects of the medication so much.
But B, are there other physical effects on your tissues
in the main tissue that you're looking for with any medication?
It's the liver because the liver has to detoxify it.
Now, there are certain detoxification pathways that we could look at genetically,
different side of chrome peep, P450 pathways,
PUD1 pathways and AT pathways and glutathione pathways.
If you have issues with any of those major detoxification pathways,
genetically, you have a possibility of greater issues in your ability to detoxify said medication.
But even if you had no defects in any of the genetic pathways,
there's other acquired issues that you could have with your liver.
Maybe you took a lot of medication, you're exposed to a lot of toxins.
You drank a lot of alcohol, whatever.
So, you already have physically impaired pathways,
even though they're genetically impaired pathways.
So, if you have any physical impairment of those pathways,
eat your liver, you're going to have a greater difficulty detoxifying a medication.
Not just bedbedness all, it's chemotherapy,
it's hypervectin or it's Tylenol, whatever it is.
You can have a difficult time getting rid of that.
So, if you don't get rid of it,
it does damage to your tissue, right?
So, whatever you don't get rid of becomes a part of you
and it can damage your cells.
And typically medications are going to do damage to your liver.
They can do damage to other things as well,
just like I just mentioned in the Brain Antibodies question.
So, if you're, you know, chemotherapy can cross the blood-brain barrier,
cause inflammation in the brain,
cause prime glial cells, cause antibodies being developed to neuronal tissue.
Well, it can same thing.
It's chemotherapy.
That only can help tip over cancer cells and kill them,
but it can also,
then catch 22 is it can damage healthy cells
because it's a very strong oxidizing agent
that doesn't spare healthy cells.
So, those are side effects of different medications.
So, there's a difference between side effects of medication
and the inability to detoxify a medication.
So, typically the problems that a person would have with metasol
is difficulty in detoxifying them and detoxifying metasol
that has to do with your genetic pathways
as well as acquired issues in those genetic pathways.
Next question.
I emailed my KBMO food sensitivity
and gut barrier permeability test results.
It shows slightly elevated candida and LPS,
LPS's lipopolysaccharides.
Zondulin and oculin were near normal.
I see several rife programs for candida,
including a few footpath programs.
Would you recommend just dietary changes or also a supplement?
I already take you to binder.
I also have oregano and tea tree and other essential oils
at the ready.
I think this is one of those things where I can herks if I go too fast.
So, how would you recommend proceeding?
OK, so, zondulin and oculin are a different chemicals
in our cells that will change constitution,
which can damage the tight junctions of your gut border
and that will open up.
So, if you have elevated zondulin or oculin,
it tells you that there's damage to those borders
and that's what's called leaky gut.
So, that's part of the gut permeability test.
So, when you're looking at how healthy is the gut barrier,
you're looking at zondulin and oculin.
If those are near normal, that's good.
But what is worse than having elevated zondulin
or oculin is elevated lipopolysaccharides?
Because that tells us that there's something that's damaged.
So, there's two different ways that things get across the gut border.
I mean, in wrong ways.
So, normally you have absorption sites for different nutrients and things like that.
But a damaged gut border will cause weakness in those tight junctions
of the cells that epithelial cells themselves and things go between the cells.
If that's what's taking place, the zondulin and oculin will be elevated.
If things are going through the cells,
that's a totally different thing.
And you'll have elevated lipopolysaccharides.
So, that's worse.
So, that's one step worse.
Now, lipopolysaccharides also can give us clues
that there's gram-negative bacteria present
and the most common gram-negative bacteria would be H-pi-loride.
So, understand there's H-pi-loride tests out there.
So, somebody may say, you know, this person at least didn't send H-pi-loride tests,
but some person may say, oh, I'm had tests for H-pi-loride and they were negative.
But I never test for H-pi-loride because they're too often incorrectly negative.
So, it's difficult because H-pi-loride doesn't just...
It's a pathogen that doesn't stay in one place.
That's the easiest way to put it.
So, if you do urea-bract test, which is a common test for H-pi-loride,
it's only going to measure, if you have H-pi-loride in the stomach.
If you do a stool sample test for H-pi-loride,
it's only going to measure if you have H-pi-loride in the gut.
And then you have to look at, did the person do an IgG-IGA or an IgM test for H-pi-loride
because those are totally different because IgG-IGA will show that you had an H-pi-loride.
At some point in time, but doesn't mean that you have it now,
IgM would test that you haven't now.
But I wouldn't trust that because you still might have H-pi-loride,
but it's not in the gut any longer.
It might have done its damage in the gut, and now it's in the bloodstream.
Well, you could do a blood test for H-pi-loride.
But that can also be negative because it's not in the bloodstream anymore.
It's in the tissues, and that's very dangerous
because that can lead to different cancers that is most commonly leads to
because it gets into the tissues that lie in the vessels that endothelial cells,
and it damages the endothelial cells,
and it is one of the primary causes of cardiovascular disease.
So elevated LPS.
So life of polysaccharides are going to be generated through a grand-negative bacteria.
So H-pi-loride is a grand-negative bacteria,
and that's the most common grand-negative bacteria worldwide.
So there's other possible grand-negative bacteria.
One is Lyme disease, Borrelia, Burgodorfia, is a grand-negative bacteria.
But no, I don't have any other symptoms of Lyme disease.
H-pi-loride would be my first guest, especially if you're having gut issues.
So an H-pi-loride is so common.
So to treat H-pi-loride, yes, I would say you see a regano,
you see deglyceride, licorice, you see garlic, you see things like that
are going to be your best bet.
Burberry is great for H-pi-loride.
Those things will be absorbed, and they will treat H-pi-loride systemically.
But you still have to be working on healing the gut,
and the other thing that I would consider with healing the gut is taking buterin.
So we have a buterin, a product from allergy research called buterin.
It's spelled a little different with EN, it's a capital E at the end,
or tributerant supreme from desides for health.
They're really the same thing.
So there's a lot of good buterin products on the market,
generational, health, I think that's called.
They have a gut health product that we sell a lot of,
but the least expensive is the allergy research buterin.
That usually does the trick.
That's a really good fuel source for the epithelial cells to help heal that.
But addressing the candida also,
the same things that work for H-pi-loride can work for candida as well.
There's other things like caprylic acid and stuff that can be beneficial for candida as well.
And certainly you can go slow on it, and I would suggest that you don't want any kind of Herk's reaction
because if you do kill any drabnegative bacteria quickly,
you're going to liberate a lot more lipopolysaccharides.
And really a Herk's reaction is mainly driven by lipopolysaccharides.
And you do have to be careful generating too much lipopolysaccharides
because lipopolysaccharides are a primary source of damage to the blood brain barrier.
So when we have damaged the blood brain barrier,
then anything can get across.
And we go back to the previous question,
that is what causes inflammation of the brain.
So things get in there that you don't want to be in there,
that are going to activate microglial cells and cause all sorts of ramped up problems.
So yes, that's how I would start trying to work on healing the gut.
Next question.
I have been taking Ivermectin for my cancer for eight months now.
Lately I've been seeing reports that the Ivermectin may be tainted.
Do you have an opinion about that?
Well, I do because I don't trust any pharmaceutical companies.
Well, that's just me, very cynical.
I apologize.
But doing this for almost 40 years now,
you tend to get cynical about the medical profession.
I'm not saying there's not a need for them.
I'm not saying there's not great doctors.
And I'm not saying there's not great medications out there and drugs out there
that have saved people's life.
But for everyone that has saved a person's life,
there's probably 10 that have killed people.
So it is, I've said over and over again that, you know,
remember that bed bed is all that Ivermectin though they are the latest.
I hate to say fan.
Okay, but I've been taking care of people with cancer since 1998 or 1999.
So 26 years now going on 27 years.
And I've seen things come and go.
Okay.
I'll use an example of Rick Simpson well.
Well, it was about five, six years ago.
Then I tell you I had three questions on Rick Simpson oil and just about every Zoom call.
It was because that's all you've heard about.
It's Rick Simpson, Rick Simpson, Rick Simpson.
That's when THC and CBD was new to the market.
And it was the hottest, latest fan in treating everything and cured everything.
Well, we've soon come to learn that CBD, well, it's a good product for a lot of things,
especially if you have CPN1 defects, genetic defects and things,
it can be very helpful.
But it is not.
There isn't a cure for everything.
There just, there isn't.
And you heard back 10 years ago to five years ago,
it's all we heard about is Rick Simpson oil for carry cancer.
Rick Simpson oil is very high, high concentration THC.
So it's very psychotropic.
And gosh, question after question about, can I use the Rick Simpson oil for this and that?
Well, it wasn't the cure at all either.
I'm not saying it didn't work for some people.
But I remember it did in Venezuela or this same thing.
You know, then about five years ago, so all we heard about is,
the Joe Tippen's protocol in Ken Medizzo.
Well, we've seen miracles with it, but we've seen, you know,
more than that many people that did it and seemingly did nothing for them.
Same thing with Ivory Bechtit.
Even though Dr. Bechtit is publishing his success stories left it right,
setting them out and figuring out his email list.
He sends you about two emails a day.
You know, the truth is, he may have, you know, 10,000 people that are following his protocol,
maybe a hundred thousand people that are following his protocol.
He's getting it, you know, I don't have that many different testimonies of success from him.
So just remember, you know, that anything can work for anybody.
And many times, it not only doesn't work, but it could do harm,
but it could do harm, especially when you're talking about a drug.
So just just keep that in mind.
Do I believe that the pharmaceutical companies are purposely,
that's the talk out there, you know, tone is that the pharmaceutical companies.
Now, you know, they were so against Ivory Bechtit during COVID,
you know, bashing it, Ivory Bechtit is bad, which is pretty hard to understand.
Why were they doing that?
When they were the ones selling Ivory Bechtit,
and they were the ones not allowing Ivory Bechtit to be sold,
could it say, they made a profit selling it?
Well, they made a bigger profit selling the vaccine.
And there was other various things going on with the vaccine.
Now we're learning that the MLRNA vaccines are cause of cancer.
We said it a long time ago, but the proof is now coming out.
The research is coming out.
So, and then all of a sudden they changed their tune about a year ago.
And yes, everybody could get Ivory Bechtit, and that made everyone suspicious.
You know, anybody that's been dealing with the medical profession of the drug companies over the years,
that puts out your little spidey senses that all of a sudden they just okayed something.
Oh, what is going on with that?
And some people have said that different independent laboratories have tested different Ivory Bechtits on the market,
and they can be tainted.
And there's people out there that said that.
Now, personally, I've never seen those studies.
I don't know if they're true.
I don't know if this is just another conspiracy theory.
I don't know.
I'm just saying that I think in Venezuela and Ivory Bechtit can be used for cancer,
and if somebody is in dire straits, and we need to do everything that doing that can be an option,
I just have to use everything with caution and a lot of prayer and be careful.
If you've been taking Ivory Bechtit for eight months now and you're stable,
I would consider going off it.
And other questions in the past where people said I don't have cancer.
My husband doesn't have cancer, but he's been taking Ivory Bechtit to prevent it.
I don't think that's a good idea.
I don't think he should be on a medication to try to prevent disease.
I don't think that's, I think he should let your body try to prevent disease.
You take nutrition, you do dietary things, you exercise, you do all sorts of things to prevent disease.
There's no research that's going to prevent a disease.
I think you could do more damage than good.
So I would be careful of that.
And if I was stable and my cancer was stable, I would go off of those things because they can do harm.
So taking fish oil can't do harm.
But, you know, taking fenmentasal can do harm.
Well, you can test for these things.
That's why I ask people to promise that you're going to go on fenmentasal,
but you've got to be getting a comprehensive metabolic profile on a monthly basis, at least.
And so you can look at their AST, ALT, and alkaline phosphatase.
And then is, you know, if there is damage to the liver, then we need to back off.
Hope that helps.
Do you accept patients that are not cancer patients?
My granddaughter is having health issues.
Yes, we do, so you could just have them call the clinic or they can self-schedule.
They just have to fill out that intake form and everybody starts the case review.
So typically on those type of people, there's not a plan or anything like that.
We really have a cancer plan.
But, yeah, would I do test it or whatever it would do?
It depends on what's going on with that person.
Next question.
If my genetics show defects in my TP53 genes,
and I'm more susceptible for other cancers.
So your TP53 genes, or commonly known as the P53 genes,
are the most researched tumor suppressor genes.
There was one of the first tumor suppressor genes discovered.
There have been books written on the P53 genes, what they do.
There's been a lot of research over the years on the P53 genes.
There are tumor suppressor genes.
Remember, tumor suppressor genes are genes inside every cell that will turn on
if the cell goes into rapid replication and stimulate a capsaic reaction that causes intrinsic apoptotic pathway progression
and causes the cell to go through apoptosis.
In short, there are genes that turn on if cancer starts to kill the cancer.
Kills the cancer from the inside out.
Kills the cell from the inside out.
If I have defects on tumor suppressor genes, then it can hinder that intrinsic pathway.
So it hinders the killing of the cancer.
So the cancer continues to progress unabated.
You can only have extrinsic, or you have less intrinsic,
so inside the cell sources that you're relying more on extrinsic outside the cell,
ways to kill the cancer.
So, for instance, you're doing things to stimulate your immune system to help kill the cancer.
You're using the right to help kill the cancer.
You're using chemotherapy to help kill cancer.
Those are all extrinsic pathways of apoptosis.
You're stimulating extrinsic pathways of apoptosis.
The chemotherapy might be trying to stimulate lysis, not necessarily apoptosis,
but pathological death in the cell.
So, when you have defects on tumor suppressor genes,
that's not good, right?
So, let's say a breast cancer and a defects on the T53 genes.
And that's at least partly the reason why my cancer has progressed to a diagnosis.
And now I'm working on extrinsic and intrinsically trying to stimulate P53.
And one of the great things to do to help stimulate the effective P53 is to take curcumin.
That's one of the interventions for the P53 gene defects.
So, even if you don't have defects on P53,
and you're taking curcumin, it's helping stimulate that intrinsic pathway of destruction.
So, but am I susceptible to other cancers?
Yeah, yeah, you are.
Yes. That's why I would be good to run your genetics.
Somebody who doesn't have cancer.
Well, if I read by genetics, before I got cancer and I phoned out,
I had P53 gene defects and I started interventions like taking curcumin,
when I have prevented cancer.
The baby? A baby? Yeah.
Which you can also say if I ate better and I was, you know, understood that toxins caused cancer
and I ran toxicity tests before this and I dealt with those things when I have prevented my cancer.
Yeah, maybe that's, that's all true.
So, the more things you, that's true, that's real prevention.
Whereas the medical professor goes, you should run early cancer screening.
That's preventative medicine is early screening.
No, it's not. It's just early detection.
It doesn't prevent anything.
So, true prevention is to look at the things that cause a disease and address those before the disease exists.
So, it would be to run toxicity tests before you have cancer, to run a genetic profile before you have cancer
and deal with those things.
Well, there's a lot of other things genetically that you could look at other than just cancer,
but, you know, you could look at, well, what's my susceptibility to Alzheimer's?
We could run a genetic profile and see where my susceptibility is.
You could run a blood test on the Alzheimer pathways and see what my susceptibility is.
So, there's different things that you can do.
That's what preventative medicine is.
And then making lifestyle changes in the hopes to prevent or to push out that disease.
So, still, I get it, but I might get it by 90s instead of in by 60s.
So, that's true preventative medicine.
So, yes, if my genetics showed defects in my TP53 genes,
am I more susceptible to other cancers?
Yes, yes, you are.
So, that's why you continue doing the right thing, even if we've knocked down the cancer,
we continue to do the right thing.
Next question.
I had an appointment with my PCP this morning regarding the thrombone pain I get in my legs,
specifically by thighs when I walk.
She recommended that I try the medication.
Plectal generic form of cellosterous all.
I'm not familiar with that medication.
That is traditionally used for intermittent clonication.
I am open to giving it a try because the pain has become crippling,
but I do not have much mobility at all as a result.
I thought I would run it by you first to see if there's any effects on circulation,
bringing more blood to the muscles.
If it would not be safe to use or not with horrible positive breast cancer.
I don't know.
Honestly, I don't know.
I would have to Google it and search for it as well.
On the home page of the member site, there's a link to Drugs.com.
You can search for any medication in there and get a list of what they have to legally list as the sign effects.
Then you can do a Google search.
There are maybe Facebook groups of people that have intermittent clonication that were on the medication.
They might tell you different things personally, what they have gone through.
I don't have any comments on that because I don't know, so looking that up would be your best bet.
Sorry about your eating your legs.
Question from the chat.
When we use the right frequency every night, do we get any benefits for our lymphatic system?
Well, I do put lymphatic drainage programs in everybody's overnight program.
But, you know, I don't, everybody responds to frequencies differently.
So everybody has also a lymphatic program on their right.
Both those that have the true endos that have the atelier, but you can run those also.
There's swelling programs that you can run.
There's inflammation programs that you can run.
Those all have very similar frequencies that are aimed at trying to decrease inflammation.
That again, when somebody comes to you with cancer, the majority of the frequencies in their overnight program are going to be cancer.
So the reason why I put all those other programs on there is that if you have other symptoms, you can run those.
So I would run some of those programs that I just mentioned separately during the day or the evening or something to help with if you have lymphatic issues.
Or if you have my swelling or something like that.
Next question.
I am scheduled to have a dreaded dental feeling tomorrow.
Your advice when I asked previously was to not do detox a couple of days before the filling.
Would that apply to the cancer program and the dental overnight program?
No, you can still run all those.
Run your cancer program. Run your dental overnight program.
If you.
I think I think it was you that asked the question that you have hard time with.
The.
A dental product that will help them to tissue all the different products that are in the market that they're going to use to different.
None of the tissue and stuff and that can be an issue and using doing a lot of detox before that is going to make it worse.
I think that's what you referred to.
I think you asked a question a few weeks ago.
But definitely run any the dental overnight, the dental folk eye programs, the dental infection programs.
Uh, I would run those.
I would honestly I would probably before this.
I'm going to skip the cancer program tonight.
Just run those overnight.
And then when you get home, put the ball right up to the to the area and your bottle to this.
Run those programs.
It's best you possibly can do that.
Any other questions?
All right.
Well, God bless all of you.
We'll see you next week.
Have a good week and enjoy the fall.
Hopefully it's beautiful, whenever you are.
And we'll talk to you next week.
Bye bye.